the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones house
of the dragon video well my friends it
looks like we finally have another
official wins of winner and house of the
dragon update from george rr martin's
not a blog website
it honestly seems like it has been a
while since we've received any new
information about the show as you all
know we are now less than four months
away from finally getting to see the
first episode of house of the dragon
hbo's new series set roughly 170 years
before the events of game of thrones and
a song of ice and fire now before we go
any further let's go over to george r
martin's website so we can see what he
had to say only a few hours ago as
always george says there is a lot going
on good things bad things big things and
small things there's no time for a long
blog just now but here are a few random
comments about all and sundry some of
which may interest some of you it looks
like the jets and giants both did very
well in the first round of the nfl draft
well i'm gonna go ahead and skip this
section of the blog i doubt any of us
are here for his thoughts on football it
goes on to say dark winds debuts in june
on amc the trailer is everywhere so
check it out if you have not seen it yet
i was one of the executive producers on
the show a six-episode adaptation of the
navajo detective novels by the late
great tony hillerman now as interesting
as this may sound i don't think any of
us are here for this either i'm sorry
george we all love you but we're all
here for one thing and one thing only he
says the winds of winter is going to be
a big book the way it's going it could
be bigger than a storm of swords or a
dance with dragons the longest books in
the series to date i do usually cut and
trim once i finish but i need to finish
first alright folks now let me just say
something about this and i will be the
first to admit maybe i am foolish for
thinking this but i have to believe that
at least george rr martin believes he
will get the wins of winner done
relatively soon i just don't see any
other reason why he would continue
reminding us about how often he is
working on it unless he feels like he's
almost done with it he knows better than
anyone else that whenever he mentions
the wins of winner he will receive a lot
of backlash for not having it finished
over the last decade if he actually knew
he would never get it done i don't see a
reason for him to mention it knowing
what kind of criticism it brings every
single time
now i know i know i go back and forth on
this myself
my thoughts and feelings about the winds
of winter flips with every single update
he blogs about but like i said at the
end of the day i just have to believe he
knows he's nearly finished otherwise i
don't see why he would always remind us
about it unless he's just downright evil
which i don't think he is
now that he's letting us know how big he
thinks it will be makes me think he's
obviously already written more than
enough to know then again who really
knows maybe he is just saying it will be
the biggest novel so he can excuse
himself for taking so long
either way i do want to stay optimistic
about this
deep down i do feel like he will get it
done sometime soon now let's see what
else he said
he goes on to say i saw rough cuts of a
couple more episodes of house of the
dragon and was just as happy as i was
with the earlier episodes ryan and
miguel and their cast and crew are doing
great work those of you who like complex
conflicted and grey characters as i do
will like the series there will be more
than enough dragons and battles to be
sure but the spine of the story is the
human conflicts the love and the hate it
will be more of a character drama rather
than an action-adventure story it will
obviously be a lot like game of thrones
only the story will not be as grand it
should be mostly contained to a few
locations like king's landing and
dragonstone unlike game of thrones where
we were constantly bouncing around from
different locations all over westeros
and essos now i do like that house of
the dragon will be more focused on the
central story but i will also miss that
adventure aspect that game of thrones
did so well
now i like battle scenes as much as the
next guy but some of my favorite moments
on game of thrones were when things were
more intimate moments when we would see
characters getting to know each other
like arya and the hound jon and egret
tyrion and braun or even bran jojen and
mira
under almost any other circumstances you
would never see these characters hanging
out with each other but because of the
situations they were in they had to lean
on each other and depend on one another
for survival
characters who at first may seem like
the odd couple but through hardships and
adversity they would form bonds with
each other that would draw them closer
than some of their own relationships
with family it's amazing moments like
these that will be missed from house of
the dragon but that doesn't mean the new
series won't make up for it in other
ways i am very anxious and excited to
see how the first season will unfold
like i said at the beginning of the
video we are now less than only four
months away from seeing that first
episode and according to george rr
martin the episodes were very well done
just like i did with the game of thrones
episodes i will start working on my
house of the dragon episode breakdown
videos immediately after each new
episode ends i'm hoping that i will see
all of you back here for those videos
when we can finally have something new
to dive into and discuss and dissect
as always make sure you are subscribed
now that way you will know whenever i
release a new video regarding anything
about game of thrones house of the
dragon the winds of winter or a song of
ice and fire i want to thank all of you
for stopping by and checking out this
short update video i hope all of you
have a great day i will see you again
very soon
bye
you